[Music]
new insight about bachelor Chris soules
and the car crash that took a man's life
Ali Fedotowsky man oh here with me again
tonight yeah Kevin I'm still so shaken
by this you know Chris and I we became
friends cuz we're both part of the
bachelor family and you know everybody
loved him he was Prince farming on the
show and everyone was rooting for him on
Dancing with the Stars yet so many fans
out there that loved him we now know
that it was Chris who called authorities
for help after the collision but why did
he disappear from the scene we start
with his frantic 9-1-1 call i rear-ended
a diner tractor is a tractor in the
ditch yeah yeah okay and the guy was
thrown into the ditch yeah it does
matter on him no no the former bachelor
star sounds frantic and emotional as he
struggles to help are you talking to Amy
conscious he's not conscious
what's your name when it's Krystal
breathing huh I can't tell does anyone
there know how to do CPR how you CPR I
can talk you through it if you're near
the pavement at this point someone at
the scene attempt CPR on the driver of
the tractor truck I feel cold yeah he's
got a pulse
AHA check to see Peter the victim later
died at the hospital from there things
went from bad to worse one of the
subjects that was involved just took off
northbound in a red Duramax
truck leave the name on the sub that's
gonna be Chris old attributed subject
that took off Souls called 911 around
8:20 2 p.m. left the scene and wasn't
arrested in to 116 a.m. that's almost 5
hours later
authorities say Souls quote possessed
alcoholic beverages / containers today
the local sheriff told us beer cans were
found at the scene but they're still
investigating who they belong to
officers were unable to conduct a field
sobriety test souls is charged with
leaving the scene of a fatal crash he
was released after posting $10,000 bail
in court yesterday the county's
assistant attorney claims souls hindered
the investigation two hours is
to retrieve mr. souls from inside of
that house in order to continue the
investigation and ex powers and appoint
mr. Schultz come out of the house or
cooperative enforcement the reality star
is back in court on Tuesday
now court documents point out that Chris
has a record of irresponsible driving
including a DUI which came before the
bachelor so my question Ali do all
female contestants get to know the
history of the bachelor before they go
on the show well no I mean everyone's
given an extensive background check but
you don't know what the other
contestants background checks were so
you aren't told anything about their
pasts now
[Music]
you